there's a price we pay for living in a
free country when you have free speech
you invariably allow people to say
stupid things
when you have very few constitutional
requirements for holding office you
sometimes elect people who actually
don't like the very country they claim
they want to represent
and this all comes crashing together in
the case of representative ilhan omar
congresswoman omar says she likes to
start fires
and claims she tries to use her race and
her religion and her gender to fuel
those fires she claims her critics are
anti-muslim and anti-immigrant and
anti-black and sexist
what if your critics just don't like it
when people say dumb things
what if your critics don't care about
your religion or your country of birth
or your
your race or your gender what if your
critics just don't like mindless
hypocrisy or the utter illogic with
which you structure your arguments
congresswoman omar also said and i quote
i don't defend or explain the rise of
crime that's not my job
and then of course she immediately
proceeds to defend and explain the rise
in crime and you'll never guess who she
blames for the crime crippling her
district
she blames the police
the police are apparently to blame for
murder and rape and robbery and
carjackings don't blame the perpetrator
don't blame the person actually
committing the crime
blame the police
in her world there is no personal
responsibility nothing is ever anyone's
fault unless you're rich or a cop or
jewish those are the the real bad guys
freedom is great but it only works if
there's a corresponding responsibility
the two cannot be separated
congresswoman omar puts the
responsibility for murder and rape and
robbery not on the people committing the
crimes but on the people who risk their
lives to prevent and solve those crimes
and the media just ignores the duplicity
when republicans say stupid things the
media is quick to report on that and we
should all be quick
to condemn irresponsible and inaccurate
remarks regardless of who makes them
but you will not see the media hold her
to account because they never do
in south carolina people who repeatedly
start fires
are called arsonists
in minnesota
they're apparently called members of
congress
freedom only works with a corresponding
responsibility i'll be looking to see
whether there is any responsibility
for a member of congress who blames
crime on everyone
except those actually committing the
crimes
and of course if she really has her way
the police will be defunded there won't
be any police
i wonder who she will blame then hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else